Alex Martelli: Welcome back
to the second part,
and now we're starting
to speak about functions.
A function is defined
by the key word def,
def, name, open paren,
parameters, close paren,
colon, body.
Note that the parentheses
are mandatory.
Even if you have
no parameters,
you just write
def, name, open, close.
That's all there is to it.
The body gets compiled
at the time
you execute def.
It gets compiled
and connected
to the function object
that is created.
The function object
is also assigned
to the name
that you're giving.
It's not executed
at this time.
Later, as in not necessarily
after that in your program text,
but later in time,
you can call the function.
The call is--
the syntax is simply
name, open paren,
arguments, close paren.
Again, the parentheses
are what makes a call.
This is going to be familiar
to any C or C++ programmer.
If you just mention the name,
you're mentioning the object.
You could put
the function object
in a list or something.
If you want to call it,
you have to have
parentheses there.
The arguments and parameters
must respond.
Arguments are
what you are--
are values that you are
initializing the names
in the parameters with.
Their correspondence is
typically one to one,
but there is a few ways
that you can use
more flexibility there.
The parameters at the end
can have default values
like in C++.
So, you can use the syntax
parameter name equal expression
meaning,
unless otherwise specified,
this object is the value
for this parameter.
Be careful, this expression
is evaluated once
at the time
you run the def statement
and that object is going
to be used for every call
that doesn't specify
that name.
You may or may not
override this
by explicitly specifying
a corresponding argument
in the call.
Similarly,
the last few arguments
you give can be named.
Instead of just taking
the positional correspondent
first argument goes
to first parameter,
second argument goes
to second parameter,
you can say explicitly
what parameter name
you're setting
to the value
you're passing.
Finally,
you may define a function
that takes
arbitrary positional
and/or arbitrary
named arguments.
The syntax is star-named.
It will give you a tuple name
of extra positional arguments,
and star, star, name
will give you a dictionary
of optional named args.
So, there's a lot
of flexibility there,
which is typically used,
for example,
to wrap a function
in another function
and pass arguments through
without needing to know
which ones they are.
Here's a simple example.
A totally elementary function,
takes two arguments,
does the sum of squares.
So, that's all
there is to it,
but it's not very general.
It will work
if we're in the middle
of computing a hypotenuse,
but what if we have
more than two numbers
and we want the sum
of their squares?
This is the Pythonic way
of expressing that.
The sum of squares,
arbitrary arguments,
is the sum of the square
for every item
in the arguments.
So, the sum of all squares
is the sum of the square
of each item.
That's just about
as high-level
as you can get
and stay general.
If you're used
to lower level languages,
you may think
in these terms.
Well, start
with a total of zero,
then go
over all arguments
incrementing the total
by the square,
and finally
return the total.
That will work, too.
As I said,
we do bend over backwards
to try and support people
who are so attuned
to lower level
programming languages
that they can't just express
their problem anymore.
But the problem you're trying
to solve is this one,
and this is much faster and
much more natural in Python.
So, if you find yourself
basically writing
for turning Python,
try and write Python instead.
It's going to be much faster
and make you much happier.
Generators are functions
which instead
of returning a value
yield values.
The key word is yield,
y-i-e-l-d,
instead of return.
What's the difference?
A return gives a result
and terminates the execution
of the function.
A yield gives a result
and suspends the execution
of the function
at that very spot
until further notice.
Specifically,
the mechanism we've used
to let you resume
and get the next result,
the next thing to be yielded,
is iterators,
which are basically objects
with a next method.
So, when you call the generator,
you get the iterator.
Every time you call next
on the iterator,
you get the next thing
to be yielded.
And when everything is done,
when there is
no more next value,
the iterator will raise
a StopIteration exception.
If you use a for loop,
remember to finish out
the for loop that
we gave in the first half,
this is basically done
for you for free.
So, I mentioned enumerate before
is actually a built-in,
but if it wasn't a built-in,
these are two ways
we could actually program it.
One is the lower-level way,
the other one is
the higher obstruction
and faster way.
So, the job of enumerate
is yielding each item
of the sequence
with its index.
So, zero, first item,
that's the first yield.
One, second item,
second yield and so on.
So, you could think,
well, I'll start at zero,
loop over the sequence,
and yield the current index,
n, and the item,
and then increment
for the next item.
So, when the yield executes,
the function freezes.
The execution
of that particular run
of the function freezes.
And when the next method is
called on the iterator,
it can by incrementing
and going back.
This is the higher abstraction
way of doing it.
It uses the standard
library module itertools,
these tools for iteration,
by doing a element by element
parallel zipping and count,
which is an iterator which
yields the unending sequence
zero, one, two, three,
and so on forever.
What we're doing is
zipping the sequence,
zero, one, two, three,
with the sequence we were
giving as an argument.
So, this single statement
does the job of these four.
Again, think in these terms
when you're programming Python.
You'll be so much happier.
Let's give a slightly
less elementary example.
One of my favorite
mathematicians of all times,
Leonardo Pisano
known as Fibonacci,
wrote an exercise
in his "Liber Abaci"
about computing the number
of rabbits produced
by a hypothetical
rabbit warren.
You're maybe familiar
with a Fibonacci sequence,
basically the sequence here.
So, we start with one, one,
and then every item is the sum
of the previous two.
So, this is a low-level,
but perfectly acceptable way
of programming.
We'll start with i and j
both equal to one.
Note something
I hadn't mentioned before,
you can change assignment
like in C.
I equal j equal one
gives both names, i and j,
to the object one.
And then while true,
which of course means
this loop will never terminate,
not per se,
we do another form
of multiple assignment.
We assign i, j, and i plus j
to r, i, and j respectively.
If this isn't
perfectly obvious,
the right hand side
with the multiple values
is evaluated left to right.
So, i and then j
and then the sum,
and after all the evaluations,
then all the name bindings.
So, r is i,
i is j,
j is i plus j.
You could write it
as three assignments,
but there's no point.
And finally, we yield
this current result.
If you just did a for on this,
this will run forever.
So, it is crucial
that the for
has a break inside it
at some point
when you have enough stuff.
So, this is,
as I mentioned,
the purpose of the exercise
was computing
the number of rabbits born
in a farm, in a certain year.
So, for rabbits
and Fibonacci,
note we have to call it
to get the iterator,
we just print it with a comma
to avoid breaking the line,
and then we decide
when to break.
We break when we have
more than 100 rabbits
because that's
a large enough farm
and this is
the result sequence.
Another trick,
which will be very familiar
to JavaScript programmers,
but is not common
in the other language,
def is
an executable statement.
I did mention there's
no such thing as a declaration,
everything is a statement.
Def is an executable statement.
Every time def execute,
it builds a new function object
and binds it to that name.
Also, scoping is lexical.
That is, if I'm looking
for a variable name
and it's not bound
in my current context,
I go to the context
containing it,
where contexts are functions
in Python.
So, consider this:
Def makeAdder given an addend.
When def makeAdder compiles,
it just compiles this--
when def, the outer def,
executed just compiles this.
When makeAdder gets called,
this def executes,
meaning this code gets compiled
and bound to name adder
and that name adder,
of an inner function,
is returned
from the outer function.
This is known as a closure.
The inner function adder doesn't
have anything named addend,
and so it looks outside
and finds it
in the outer function.
So, for example,
a23 equal makeAdder(23).
Now, a23 is a function
that will sum 23
to whatever it's given.
And similarly makeAdder(42),
so now a42 is function
that will sum 42
to whatever is given.
So, we can print a23(100),
a42(100) or compose them,
they're totally independent now,
because every def,
every time the inner def runs,
it builds a new function object,
but you don't interfere,
so we have
the expected results.
A syntax form known
as decorators makes
higher order functions
even smoother to use in Python.
Basically, whenever you write
at decorator def something
or in Python 2-6,
which is about to go beta now,
similarly for
at decorator class something,
but we won't be covering
anything beyond 2-5.
Whenever you write this,
it's as if you've done your defs
or created your function object,
and then rebound the same name,
which you used in the def,
to whatever happens
passing the function object
as the argument
to the decorator.
So, basically, decorator has
to be a higher order function
or it could be
a call to a function
returning a higher
order function,
a higher order
squared function.
This is a very handy syntax
for all sorts of things.
Particularly it's used
in side classes as we'll see.
Okay, there's new-style classes
and old-style classes.
I will not be mentioning
old-style classes at all.
They're totally obsolete,
only exist
for backwards compatibility.
We'll talk
about new-style ones.
A class is similar to a def.
In a sense,
it's also a key word.
Class, the name,
and then bases in parenthesis.
If you have no bases--
Well, you should always have
at least object as a base.
So, at the very least,
you'll have open paren, object,
close paren, and then a body.
So, it's different
from a def in this sense:
As I mentioned, when you call--
when you execute def,
the body only gets compiled,
not executed yet.
When you execute class,
the body gets executed.
The body's typically a series
of assignment and def
and possibly other statements
and it's executed at the time
you execute class.
It basically binds names
to values
and those names become
attributes of the class.
So, functions, for example,
become methods for the class.
Also, anything that is
an attribute of a base
is also found when you look up
things on the class itself,
except that you can override
just like in C++ or Java.
If something is defined
in a base class
and you define it differently
in the drive class,
the drive class wins.
So, in C++,
this is likely different
because you explicitly
have to say
that something is virtual
in Python.
Like in Java,
there's no such need.
Everything can
be overridden.
Let's give a very boring example
just to show.
So, class eg,
that's just an example,
iterates from object,
that means it has no real basis,
just the multi-generic object
of them all.
It starts with assigning
an empty list to cla,
so that's a class attribute.
The class itself
holds the list,
and then it has a def
with the special name
dunder init dunder.
That's the initializer
for the instance of the class
which is called self.
And so it binds
the new dictionary,
empty dictionary,
to self.ins,
which is an attribute
of the instance,
not of the whole class.
And then,
we have two methods.
One does append
to the class attribute,
and this one does an insertion
into the instance attribute.
How we instantly change classes
is simply by calling them.
There is no need
for such redundant operators
as new.
We just call the class
and each time we call the class,
we get a fresh new instance.
So, having
just initiated them,
I see that the cla
of the instances
is the empty list
because since the instance
doesn't have one,
it goes back to the class
and the ins
our empty dictionary,
there's one per instance.
Once I've called
a few methods,
note that the cla is
the same for both
while the ins has changed
because one is a class attribute
and the other is
the instance attribute.
So, if I ask
are they identical objects?
Are they the same object
for the cla?
The answer is true because
they both go to the class,
while if I ask it
for the ins,
which is by instance,
then the answer is false.
They're not the same object.
When, uh--
Python is kind of peculiar
among very high-level languages
because it tries to make
everything very explicit
for you.
Remember that rule
in the Zen of Python:
explicit is better
than implicit.
In particular,
what does it mean
to look up an attribute
on something
that is very clearly,
very detailedly specified?
So, for example,
normally something like inst,
dot, method, arg1, arg2
will be exactly like
looking at the method
on the type of the instance
and passing the instance
as an implied
first paragraph.
More generally, whenever
you do inst dot name,
whether you are about to call it
or not doesn't matter.
There's a single namespace
for executable
and non-executable attributes.
First of all,
the string name is looked up
as a possible key
into a dictionary
which belongs
to the instance.
Every object,
just about every object,
owns a dictionary
with a special name,
dunder, dict, dunder,
which is basically
where all of its attributes
are organized.
If it's not there,
then we try the same thing
for the type
that is the class.
Type and class are more or less
synonyms in Python,
except class is a key word
and type is
a normal identifier.
If it's there, then we try
exactly the same thing
along all the bases.
The base classes
are recorded as one
of the attributes
of the type,
as part
of the class statement.
If we haven't found it
in any of the bases,
then we try a special method,
dunder getattr dunder,
which is basically there
to let you compute
attributes on the fly
just in time
when necessary.
If that works,
then it's a result,
otherwise you finally get
an attribute error
which is
an exception meaning
that attribute name
does not exist anywhere
in the search space,
for this instance.
Now, subclassing,
and this is where
overriding gets in,
means you can specify that eg
is a base class of sub,
and then you can define
the same thing,
the same name,
meth 2 in this case,
that you had already defined
in the base class
and this is an override.
In the override,
you can call the method
on the base class explicitly
by base class dot meth2.
And remember, in this case,
you have to pass
self explicitly
or you can do it implicitly
with a super,
which is a kind
of magical piece of--
a magic built-in
which does the look-up
in the base classes
for you.
So, another example is that
you can override data as well.
So, I've defined
a subclass of list
where every append is
actually done twice.
So, basically every time
you append something,
it's appended twice
to the list.
Not particularly useful,
just an example.
The point is to show
that when you subclass,
you can override
a piece of data,
in this case cla,
just as much as
you can override a method.
Again, there is
no distinction,
just define it
with a different name.
Every use
of that attribute
will use
the overridden attribute.
Another very useful concept
is that of a property.
Suppose you have two method,
call them getter and setter.
Getter just takes the object
and returns a value.
Setter takes the object
and a value
and somehow sets
the value appropriately
into the object.
You can give
a very nice syntax
by calling the built-in property
with a getter and setter,
as part of the class
assigning it to a name.
Now, every time
you access that name,
Python internally calls
the getter method for you.
And every time you assign
something to that name,
it calls the setter method
for you.
So, that's very nice syntax
to be substituted
to do function calls,
do method calls.
Note that I did say
you cannot override the equal.
That only applies
when the left hand side
is a simple identifier.
When the left hand side
is like here,
a attribute excess,
you can actually do
pretty advanced stuff
even to the assignment,
and property does it
for you.
Why am I dwelling so much
on properties?
Because there's a bean
going around
particularly in Java,
but to some extent
in C++ as well,
that you should not
expose attribute.
To keep flexibility,
you should hide attributes
behind getter
and setter methods.
Thanks to properties,
this is useless in Python.
You just expose the interesting
attributes directly.
If and when you need
a getter and a setter,
you write them
and you drop them
into a property,
so that all client-code
using your class
doesn't need to be changed.
It can still assign
to attributes C attributes,
and then method calls
will happen intrinsically
on your behalf.
Avoid boilerplate.
Don't waste pixels.
Do not code this kind of thing,
just name the attribute
without the leading underscore
so it's visible
and let people
use them and rapid,
if and when
that becomes necessary.
I did mention Python
has operator overloading.
How does it do
operator overloading
is by defining a huge number
of special names.
Special names start and end
with two underscores.
Two underscores,
you could say
underscore-underscore,
but that's a bit long,
so a common way
of pronouncing it
is dunder,
for double-underscore.
Anything beginning and ending
with dunder is reserved
to the Python language.
Do not use this form
of identifier
for your own
arbitrary names.
They could conflict
with special names
in the future.
There's a lot of things
you can do with special method.
There's a constructor, new,
initializer, init.
Note there is a difference
between constructing
and initializing.
If you're familiar
with the so-called two-step
constructor design pattern,
Python gives that to you.
New actually makes a new object
that's still bare,
and init let's you
initialize the object.
Del, which is what happens
when the object goes away.
It's not a destructor,
it's more of a finalizer.
If you're familiar
with C++ destructors,
that's a bit different.
This is more like
a Java finalized.
And then, there is a way
to convert things,
not just to wrap
a string into flow,
too complex, and so on.
Many ways
to compare things:
less than,
greater than, equal.
A lot of method
for arithmetic:
addition, subtraction,
multiplication.
Methods to make it
like a function,
so callable, hashable,
so it can go
into a setattr dictionary.
Dealing with attempts to get
set and delete attributes
or items as in a container,
other container stuff.
Getting set to define
what are called descriptors.
Enter and exit describe
what are called contexts.
So, there's a huge number
of special methods
you may want to define.
The point to retain,
you will find out
the special methods,
which are basically
a high syntax convenience,
if and when
you need them.
Python will call the type
special method for you
when you attempt
the appropriate operation.
So, for example,
when you write
foo, open, close,
Python looks up
the type of foo,
finds the dunder call method,
and that's what gets called.
It would be like operator,
open, close, paren in C++
and sometimes it does so
in a more structured way.
For example, if you ask
if a greater than b,
and a doesn't
have a gt method,
Python continues by looking
if b as an lt method,
so that it's basically
going to compute
as a second possibility
if b is less than a
rather than if a
is greater than b.
More generally, built-ins
do things right for you,
but let's get
a simple example first.
Remember the Fibonacci generator
we did a few minutes ago?
This is the same thing done
much more detailedly as a class.
At initialization,
we set one to i and j.
It's got to be self.i
and self.j
because of
their instance attribute.
We have to specify
an iterator by saying
if somebody wants to iterate
and use me directly.
And then there's the next,
which is unfortunately
not marked by dunder.
This is fixed in Python 3.0,
but this is in Python 2.
We didn't place
the double-underscore,
but it is a special method
because it's called,
for example,
by the for loop.
And this does essentially
the same thing
that we did more simply
in the generator,
but it does it explicitly
with self dot variables,
and this is basically
intended to be used
in exactly the same way
as the generator I gave before.
So, it's exactly
the same semantics.
Basically,
what the generator does
is generate for you an object
which is more or less like this.
Okay, built-in functions are
what calls the special methods.
You never call a special method
directly, essentially.
Think
of the double-underscore
as a way to make
special method ugly,
so you're not even tempted
to call them.
Never call x, dot, dunder,
len, open, close.
Call len, open, x, close,
it will do the right job,
which in this case is
calling dunder len.
Another example, abs,
don't call this directly.
You don't really know
what the abs built-in does.
It will probably call
dunder abs,
but suppose
it doesn't find it?
It may be able to do
a change sign test
if greater than zero changes
the sign for you.
It may or may not,
but always go through
the built-in function.
There are a lot
of built-in functions,
not just ones corresponding
directly to special methods.
We'll see some of them
in examples.
And also, these are
just the ones
that are always
available to you,
but there's a lot
in the standard library
that you want to use
just as much,
and these are all
absolutely crucial modules
in the standard library
you'll need to be
very familiar with
to do effective use
of Python.
As I said, rather than going
into these in details,
I like to give an example.
Suppose we have
a readable file somewhere.
We'd like to make an index
that is a map
from the words
in the file
to the line numbers
where that word is found.
So, first we build the map,
and then we emit it.
To build a map, we start
with an empty dictionary.
A dictionary is natural way
to represent a mapping.
We use
with open, filename, as f,
syntaxed to open it
and guarantee it's closed
as soon as we're out
out of this block.
We use enumerate
to get line numbers
and generally looping
on a file
gives you the lines
of the files or strings.
And then, we call
the split method
which breaks a line
into a list of words
and to loop over that.
And here, we use the setdefault,
which is a bit complicated
because basically
what it does is
it looks up this key
in the dictionary.
If it's there, it returns
what corresponds to it,
The corresponding value.
If it's not, then it sets
the second argument
as the new value
for the key.
So, it's kind
of complicated,
but basically
you take either a list
already corresponding
to the word
or a new empty list.
In either case, you append
the line number to it,
so the line numbers
accumulate.
And then,
once we have our index,
we can just emit it
to standard output
in alphabetical order.
So, for that,
we use a sorted built-in
which let's you loop on it
in a sorted way,
so sorted order for strings
is alphabetical,
so you loop on the words
in order and you print them.
I'm using the percent
for marking here
just to have a colon
attached to it,
and then we print
the line numbers.
Note the comma here,
so we don't break the line,
and finally a print
without anything
just to break the line
at the very end.
We can do it
slightly simpler
if we're familiar
with the standard library
because the collections module
has a sub-type of dict
known as a defaultdict.
A defaultdict is something
that if you try to index it
and the index isn't there,
the key isn't there,
instead of raising
a key error
it calls something
to make the new item.
In this case, we want to call
the type list without arguments
to make an empty list
and set it there.
So, once we've made
a collections defaultdict list
instead of a plain dictionary,
we can simply use
index word append(n)
instead of having to go
the complicated
set default route.
Everything else,
every other bit of code
in this slide,
is just the same.
Other things we could do
that could be interesting:
once we have this index,
what about getting
the seven most popular words
in the text files?
What are the seven words
that appear on most lines
in this file?
Well, for this purpose,
we want to use heapq.
Typically, it's a typical
priority heap operation,
if you're familiar
with your algorithms,
and specifically it exposes
heapq.nlargest.
Give me the n largest items
of a certain collection
and the n we want is seven,
the collection is indx,
and we get to define
what is the key extractor
for the comparison.
So, key equal index.get means
we're not getting the seven
alphabetically largest,
but the seven
whose corresponding value index
is largest,
and this will work.
And this is an end walk form
that is--
I don't want all the lines
with the word rabbit
or all the lines
with the word hare.
I want the lines
with both rabbit and hare.
How am I gonna find them?
This is a set
intersection problem.
So, I'm basically going
to simply make a list
of all the words
I'm looking for,
pop the first item,
and make a set out of
the corresponding line numbers,
and then I'm using
the ampersand operator
to do intersection
specifically in the form
ampersand equals,
so intersect in place.
Basically, all binary operators
have an equal form,
so, for example,
plus equal increments in place
and ampersand equal
intersects in place.
And, in the end, of course,
I'm careful to sort it
so it will print out nicely
in alphabet, in line order.
Because the set,
by making a set,
I get very fast intersection
and so on,
but I lose significant order
because a set is a hush table,
so it basically, as I mentioned,
doesn't have
an intrinsic order.
But when I do need it,
I can always sort it on the fly.
So, I mentioned that
that standard library
is full
of very useful modules.
To access anything
in the standard library
or any other module,
you have to import the module
and this is
how you do it.
I already showed it
in a couple of examples,
but import modulename
is the economical way.
So, for example,
when I wanted to use
something in collections,
I started
with import collections.
This basically makes the name
collections available
to my program.
And the name collections
refers to that module,
so then I can use
the attributes of the module
in my program.
If a module is contained
in a package,
you will see exactly what
a package is in a second,
then I cannot
just import it
because it's hiding
inside a package.
I have to tell Python
from what package
to import it.
This would be a package
named package
inside a package
named given
inside a package named some.
So, some dot given
dot package,
Python would look for some
inside of given,
inside of package,
and inside that for modulename.
In either way,
you basically get the modulename
as part of your namespace
and you can access it.
And then,
you want function blah
from the module,
just do modulename dot blah
and you're done.
So, there are
some other ways.
I did mention that we'd
rather have only one way,
but sometimes
it's kind of inevitable
to offer more than one.
Although in practice
these two will
make you happy
all the time,
you should be aware
of the others
because you'll see them used
in Python examples and code.
One possibility is
you can import the module
under an assumed name.
Basically, put a false mustache
on the module
so it makes believe
in your namespace
that it's named
something different
and that is the as clause.
So, for example,
suppose somebody gives you
a name that is--
this name is far too long
and this name is far too long
to use conveniently,
and you would like to have
a shorter name for it.
Well, this is
how you do it.
Import thisnameisfartoolong
as a set,
and now instead of
thisnameisfartoolong dot blah,
you can use zed dot blah.
And this is indeed
sometimes useful
if you ever have
to handle modules
whose names
are far too long.
Tips I don't recommend is
instead of getting the module
into your namespace,
reach into the module namespace
and grab one thing into yours
from thisnameisfartoolong
import blah.
This will work, but throughout
the rest of your code
people who are reading it,
including yourself
when you're maintaining it
in six months,
will wonder
where's this blah from,
and you will have to go and
look for when it was imported.
So, I'd rather always see
modulename.blah or z.blah
to get the immediate thing.
It's not a top level name,
it's coming from something else.
And the very worst thing
is to import star,
which basically grabs all
of the items in the namespace
and injects them into yours.
Don't do that.
That is a guaranteed way
to cause yourself headaches.
It's handy if you're
at the interpreter prompt
because say you're doing a lot
of math interpreter prompt,
you don't want to say
math dot syn, math dot cos,
math dot tan, math dot atan.
You want
syn, cos, tan, atan
and all
the mathematical functions
to be part
of the top namespace
because it's too much
typing otherwise.
That's possibly
the only reasonable way
to use the import star.
And this is,
to clarify what I just--
So, I want to compute
an arctan with two inputs.
The normal way is
to import math,
and then use math.atan2
of x and y,
which in this case
is this value.
If I tried even after importing
to just use atan2,
this would give
a NameError exception
because,
in my current namespace,
there is no name
atan2 defined.
Remember, I got math
into my namespace,
but atan2 is still
within namespace math.
I could do,
from math import, atan2.
In this case,
this would inject atan2
in my namespace.
Sometimes, when you're doing
this interactively
like at the prompt,
it's kind of nice.
In real programs,
it tends to be confusing
and this goes squared.
From math import star,
now you have
25 mathematical functions
in your namespace
which is handy,
but don't do it
in real programs,
only in interactive use.
So, this is nice about
how I use other modules,
but how do I make
my own modules?
Well, that's easy.
Any Python program
is a module.
Any dot py--wot dot py
Just put it
in the appropriate directory,
say the same directory
as the one
it's being imported from,
the rules depend a bit on--
but for Google App Engine
that's what you do.
And then, any other module
in that directory
can do import wot
and Python will look
for wot.py.
The directories are listed
in sys.path,
and they need not
be directories strictly.
In general,
they could be zipped files.
So, instead of having
a file system,
you can basically
zip everything up
and Python will
find it anyway.
That's kind of handy.
There are other things
that you can import.
You could import
byte code files.
You could import files
coded in C
or other languages
for Python.
So, the extensions
are pyc, pyd,
or sometimes dot so
on Linux,
but this wouldn't work
in Google App Engine.
Google App Engine
only accepts the dot py files,
so you want to make sure
you place the dot py itself.
It handles the compilation
to bytecode
in making sure
the bytecode is secure
and everything else
under the covers.
So, this variant is nice
for other kind
of uses of Python,
but don't rely on it
on the application engine.
So, what's a module?
Well, it's an object.
Everything is an object.
It's got attributes.
That's basically
everything it has.
It doesn't have
anything sophisticated,
only attributes.
The attributes
of the module object
are what you could see
as the top-level names
of the module as a source.
So, for example,
say we have a module
whose dot py source
is only x equals 23.
This is called
wot dot py.
If we import wot,
then the only thing there is
in it is wot dot x,
which is 23
and that's all.
Besides assignment,
names can be bound
by class, def,
import, and from.
Class name binds the name,
def name binds the name,
import name binds the name,
from foo bar import name
binds the name.
The attributes of a module
are also known
as the global variables
of that module.
Note there are no such things
as global globals in Python.
Globals are always
per module.
Within that module,
you can of course access them
as bare names
from other modules,
who will access them by
modulename dot variablename.
Note again,
well, variables,
but can they be
functions or classes?
Yes, there's no distinction.
Names are names are names.
Whether they're callable or not,
they're just attributes.
You can also bind and unbind
module attributes
from the outside,
a practice known
as monkey patching.
I would strongly
recommend against that
in production code.
Unless you're fixing some bug
in a library
which you're not allowed
to edit, don't do it.
Sometimes it's handy
for testing,
but there are better ways.
Use the dependency injection
design pattern,
you will do your testing
in a much more systematic way.
I would strongly recommend
avoiding monkey patching.
If you look
for monkey patching on the web,
you'll find very strong
diatribes for and against it
for every language
that's supported besides Python
including Ruby, JavaScript,
and so on.
It moves a lot of emotion.
Basically, people who are
programmers at heart
don't want to do it,
but all these languages
are used by people
who need to program
but aren't programmers.
They're like hardware experts
or web experts and so on,
and they don't see why
they should do things
the proper way,
but I'll leave that
to the web.
It's important to notice
that modules are singletons.
They are the most natural
and Pythonic form of singletons.
They're automatic singletons.
What does it mean?
It means that if you import
a module more than once,
the first import is treated
very differently
from all the following ones.
The first import finds
the module somewhere,
loads its composite
on the fly if needed
or takes the compiled form,
executes the body
of the module,
so the module object
is properly populated,
and places the module
in a system directory
known as sys dot modules.
Sys is itself a module,
so you can import sys
if you want to play
around with it,
and sys dot modules
is a dictionary.
The keys are the names
of modules.
The values are
the module objects.
So, when you import
the module again,
Python will first look
into sys.modules.
It's very, very fast to check
if something is in a dictionary.
If it finds the name,
that's what it
gives you immediately,
basically one instruction.
No second loading,
no further execution--instant.
Your singleton
is right there.
So, some people who love
the singleton design pattern
say, "Well, yeah,
this kind of works,
"but it only
gives me a module.
It can't--I can choose
a class instance there."
So, for example,
I want my singleton object
to support addition
or greater than comparison,
and I can't do that because
modules are simple objects.
Even if you define
a function called
under, under, add, under, under,
it won't do anything.
It's not as special
because it's not part
of the type of the module.
Remember,
the special methods only work
if they're in the type,
not in the instance.
So, this is how you stick
something that's not a module
into sys.modules.
Some people
consider it a trick,
I consider it
a perfectly legitimate use
of a mechanism that Python
exposes for your users.
Of course,
it's a very advanced one,
but it's a way to make--
Oh, by the way, dunder name
is a special attribute,
which is the name
of the current module.
And that's how you
basically make your class
and underscoring front
just to indicate
it's actually private
and intended
for internal purposes,
and there you go.
Packages are essentially modules
containing other modules
and, of course,
there is no limit
to nesting
you can do this way.
So, you can have sub-packages
and so on.
In practice, it lives typically
in a file system
or it could be
in a zipped file.
In a directory--
And how you
distinguish directories,
which are just directories
from directories
which are packages,
is by the presence
of a file called
dunder, init, under, under,
init, under, under, dot, py.
Python will only consider
for a package as such
a directory which has a file
by that name.
So, that file contains
the module body.
It's often empty because
you don't necessarily want
the package to do
anything else
than containing other modules.
And so, you don't need
to do anything in init py,
but you still need
to have it there
because it acts as a flag
to Python
that, yes, this is not
just any directory,
this is a package.
The modules
inside the packages are
basically all the py files
in that directory.
And that is done for you
by Python,
so you don't need
to worry about it.
And if you want sub-packages,
you will have sub-directories
which in turn need to contain
the special dunder init
dunder file.
Note that the parent directory
of the directory package
must be on sys.path.
And once you have a package
with a module bar inside it,
you could import
foo dot bar,
that will work,
it will bind foo dot bar.
So, you'll bind foo
and give it an attribute bar,
but a more normal,
more common approach is
to use
a from foo import bar
that only binds
the name bar directly.
So, basically,
I like my imports
to always bind a module
to a name,
and this is what it does.
Okay, now we've
basically covered,
well, so to speak
the Python language
and a little bit
of the built-ins
in a very tiny fraction
of the standard libraries.
One of the mottos of Python
is "Batteries Included."
It means that the standard
Python library
has more than 200 modules.
That's production modules.
There is many more
for unit-tests,
encoders, decoders, demos
of various kinds, and so on.
Some are pure Python,
some are coded in C.
The application engine
will support
any pure Python module
and most C-coded modules
that are part
of the standard library.
There are specific limitations
that will be covered
in the App Engine sessions.
App Engine does not
allow you to do threads,
does not allow you
to do sockets.
That's not because
they're encoded in C,
it's because of its very
specific execution model.
Moreover, App Engine will add
some specific APIs
such as datastore, users,
urlfetch, mail,
and will support any pure
Python module you use.
You just put as part
of your App Engine application
any dot py that doesn't use
anything except other dot pys,
and you'll be fine.
It will be supported.
But back
to the standard library,
the standard library is
so much larger than language
that the time it takes
for an expert programmer
to master Python the language
is maybe a couple of days.
Unfortunately,
when he's done that,
he's still got
a lot of work to do
because he probably wants
to know the built-ins
and the special methods,
and the metaprogramming
introspection and so on
and that takes another
say three days.
Good, but now he needs
to get started
with a standard library.
Out of the 200 modules,
there's maybe 20 or 30
which are an absolute must
and those will take another
10 days or a bit more.
And when those are done,
to really claim
they've mastered Python
as opposed
to the Python language,
they probably really want
to have a pretty good idea
of what's everywhere
in the standard library
that's longer than
all of the above.
And when they're done
with all this,
well, there's
third-party offerings.
I don't know how familiar
you are with Monty Python,
in honor of which
Python the language is named.
This is a scene
from their cheese shop sketch,
which I strongly recommend.
Cheeseshop dot python dot org
is a little bit less green,
but better supplies
than this cheese shop.
It's got 4,000 packages
and counting,
but I've given up
on printing the exact name
because whatever
I looked up yesterday
would probably already
be false today.
There's more than one package
being added every day.
It's always fun
to roll your own.
I mean,
if we're programmers,
it is because
we like to program.
Say I need this functionality,
I'll roll my own.
Unfortunately, that's not
a very professional attitude.
You probably want to see
who else already spent
person-years of effort
into doing this,
and this is likely to be
on the cheese shop.
How long does it take
to learn all 4,000 packages?
Well, I have no idea.
I suspect that if you
put yourself to it,
by the time you're finished
there will be 4,000 more,
so you'd never be finished.
So, I have no real suggestion
here except ask around.
Go to the mailing list
or go to the usenet group
and just ask,
"I need to do this and that.
Is there some good module
you could recommend?"
You'll probably get
several recommendations.
That's still a lot of work
for you to pick the best one,
but better than nothing.
Remember, online resources,
don't forget those.
They're all great.
You really need that
to do really good work
in Python.
And here we are.
We're ready
for questions and answers.
We've got about eight minutes,
so I can field quite a few.
If you can please walk
to the mic in the corridor
and speak your question
in the mic.
man: One question.
Google is hosting
Dojo and jQuery,
the JavaScript libraries.
Martelli: I'm sorry?
man: Google is right now hosting
for JavaScript development--
Martelli: I can barely--
There's a lot of--
man: Is this better?
Martelli: Yes, please.
man: Okay.
Google is hosting
some JavaScript libraries
that you can load
directly from Google
like jQuery and Dojo
and so forth.
I wonder if there's plans
for hosting
the stack of third-party
modules from Python
that you can pull directly?
Martelli: The reason
it makes sense--
I'm not a JavaScript expert,
but I believe
that the JavaScript libraries
you require, you mentioned,
would typically be mentioned
in another JavaScript file
or a web page
and having a url,
at which there's certain
to be some use.
Python doesn't work
like that.
Python doesn't load
code transparently
from across the web.
You put your code
right there.
So, there's a lot of hosting
of open source code
that we do
at code.google.com,
but that's something
you download
and integrate
with your programs.
It doesn't live
at any specific url
because that basically would
serve no useful purposes.
man: Yeah, I know.
I just thought it would
be a cool idea, sorry.
Second man: I see a lot
of similarities
between Python and Ruby,
and I'm wondering
what you think are
the major distinctions
between the two languages?
Martelli: You could look
for my name
and the words
Ruby and Python,
and you'll find
about half a dozen places
where I've written
pretty long essays.
But to summarize,
if I was doing a spanning tree
on the dag of distances
of programming languages,
I think the first two qualities
as being the closest
would be Ruby and Python.
From the point of view of
just about anybody experienced
in just about
any other languages,
they're closer
than any two other languages
could possibly be.
My favorite, being Italian,
is that they're like
spaghettini
and capelli d'angelo.
Yes, I could explain
the difference.
It's gonna be hard
if you're not Italian,
but I could.
Like whether
the microscopical round
are rounded or squared,
but in practice,
if you're eating them,
I challenge you
to tell the difference
unless you're Italian,
in which case you can.
But it's like
in the genes.
Second man chuckling:
So, I guess my question--
Martelli:
So, they're so similar.
You can dwell
on the differences,
but why?
In terms
of practical consideration,
Python is much more mature,
so the implementation are
of a much higher quality
because they've been around
so much longer
and Ruby's very fashionable.
So, do you want something
solid and working
or do you want something
that's, like,
in the news
and top of fashion?
Your pick.
[audience laughing]
I'm an engineer.
I want solid working stuff.
Somebody who'd rather be cool
can make a different choice.
Second man: Are rails and jango
also sort of analogs?
Martelli: Yes,
except in this case
rails has been
around longer.
So, in this case, rails is
more mature than jango.
Jango's getting there,
but it's not quite as rich
as rails is.
Second man: Thank you.
Martelli: Mm-hmm.
Third man: How much of this
would we have to unlearn
when Python 3 comes out?
Martelli: [sighs]
So, I did specifically mention
that you can finally
unlearn the distinction
between plain strings
and unicode strings.
Just about everything else
I mentioned
is still true
in Python 3.
Python 3 removes
a lot of stuff
that has to be kept around
for backwards compatibility
because as long as we're talking
about Python 2-dot-something,
well, it has
to keep compatibility.
That's a constraint
we gave ourselves.
Python 3 can
break compatibility
and therefore can eliminate
redundant ways to do things
that you don't
really need anymore.
You do have--I did mention
the next gains
double-underscores
before and after,
that's about it.
Third man: Well, I've heard
that very simple programs
like
the "Hello World" program--
Martelli: Oh, yeah,
print becomes a function
instead
of a statement, right,
so you'd need
parentheses then.
Third man:
Okay. All right.
Martelli: Pretty simple.
Fourth man: So, you mentioned
that monkey patching
is considered bad, but--
Martelli: By some,
and it's considered wonderful
by others and--
Fourth man:
In the Python community,
I guess you in particular
have an issue
with monkey patching,
but not directly assigning
to a module to add
additional functionality.
Is there a fundamental
difference there
that you see or--
Martelli: Fundamental difference
between what and what?
Fourth man:
Between monkey patching
and directly assigning
to a module?
Um, or are they--
From my point of view,
they're both--
Martelli: Assigning--
assigning--
modifying a module
from outside
is monkey patching.
That's my definition
of monkey patching.
Fourth man: I guess,
in particular,
is there a reason that one
is a useful feature
of the language and one
is something to avoid?
Martelli: Mm, I--
It's useful
to be able to fix bugs
without editing the buggy code,
but it's not something
that you should need to do
in the long run
in production.
I'd much rather
fix the code,
edit the source code
and fix it.
Fourth man: Okay, thank you.
Fifth man: Are there any plans
to formally support
the notion of interfaces?
I know frameworks like--
Martelli: Python 3 has
a standard library module
called Abstract Base Classes,
ABC,
which is more powerful
than interfaces in some way,
although some people think
it's less powerful than others.
That's basically what
we'll have as part
of the standard library.
Otherwise, you can get
third-party packages
which support
interfaces strictly,
but there's some stuff
that adds absolutely
no functionality,
but it makes
you look good.
Fifth man: Is this
somehow at odds
with the idea that
you want to trust programmers?
Martelli: No,
actually it's--it's--
There's nothing against
trusting programmers
and letting people use
abstract base classes.
The point is eliminate
some redundancy.
An interface per se
is a structural--
well, a way
to structure your stuff.
It doesn't really eliminate
much redundancy.
So, I'd normally rather--
I mean, if you look at some
of the ABCs in Python 3.0,
they don't actually
use the ability
to add functionality.
They work as if
they were interfaces, so...
And you can use--
So, basically, instead
of just having one way
when you're asking me
is something a container,
I can tell you,
well, it is a container
if and only if
it matches the container
of such base classes,
that kind of thing.
Fifth man: Thanks.
woman: We're out of time.
Martelli: Okay. Sorry.
Right, so we're done.
Thank you very much.
[audience applauding]